Before we dive into the
heart of the subject,
I want to make a few comments
on the different problem
types that show up in
the field of inference.
You can think of a
general distinction
between model building
versus making inferences
about unobserved variables.
We said a little
earlier that one
of the main uses of
the field of inference
is to construct models
of certain situations.
But in many cases, we
already have a model.
On the other hand, there may
be variables that are unknown,
that are unobserved-- variables
that are part of the model,
but whose values are not known.
In such cases, we
still want to use
data to make some
predictions or decisions
about those
unobserved variables.
So model building might or
might not be part of the problem
that we're dealing with.
To illustrate the difference
between these two versions
of the problem, let us
think of a concrete setting.
You have a transmitter
who is sending a signal.
Call it S. And that signal
goes through some medium.
It could be just the atmosphere.
And what that medium does
is that it attenuates
the signal by a
certain factor, a.
And then as the signal travels,
it also gets hit by some noise,
call it W, and what the
receiver sees is an observation,
X. So the situation is described
by this simple equation here.
This situation often brings
up the following inference
problem.
We want to find out
what the medium is.
How do we do this?
We send a pilot
signal, S, that is
a signal that we
know what it is.
We observe X, and then
using this equation,
and, knowing that W
is random noise coming
from some distribution,
we try to make
an inference about
the variable a.
So this is an instance
of model building.
We're trying to make a model
of the medium that's involved.
But we can also think
of a different problem.
Suppose that we know
what the medium is.
Perhaps we already went through
this particular phase here.
But we're sitting
at the receiver,
and we do not know
what has been sent.
And we want to
find out what S is.
So we are looking
again at this equation.
This time we know
a, and we're trying
to make inferences about S.
You notice that these two
versions of the problem
are essentially of the same
mathematical structure.
We have a linear equation.
In one case, we know S.
We want to find out a.
In the other case, we know a.
We want to find out what S is.
So even though
the interpretation
of these two problems
[is] quite different,
the mathematical structure
is exactly the same.
This is fortunate.
It means that one and
the same methodology
would be applicable to
both types of problems.
There is another distinction
between problem types
which turns out to be a
little more substantial.
There are problems that we call
hypothesis testing problems.
In those problems the
unknown takes one out
of a few possible values.
That is, we may have a
few different alternative
models of the world.
And we're trying to figure
out which one of those models
is the correct one.
We're going to decide in favor
of one of the candidate models,
and what we want to
achieve is that we
make a correct decision.
Or if not, we want to
have a small probability
of making an incorrect decision.
An example of this kind is
the radar detection problem
that we had discussed in the
very beginning of this course,
in which we were
getting a signal.
We were getting a radar reading.
And the question was
to make an inference
whether the radar is
seeing an airplane
or whether an airplane
is not present.
So in hypothesis
testing problems,
we're essentially
making a choice
out of a small number of
discrete possible choices.
Instead, in estimation
problems, the unknown quantities
are more of a numerical type.
They could even take
continuous values.
And what we want
to do is to come up
with an estimate of an
unknown quantity that
is close to the true but
unknown value of the quantity
that we're trying to estimate.
So here, our
performance objective
is in terms of some kind
of distance function.
We want to be
close to the truth.
And typically, we have a
continuum of possible choices
that is, our estimates can
be general real numbers.
Generally speaking, these two
types of problems, hypothesis
testing and estimation, have
some significant differences
in the way that
they are treated,
as we will be seeing next.